three two one
action hey guys welcome back to off the
record we talk about whatever we want
wrong shiny night i know you've been
startled gina
i forgot i was holding the paper and not
the microphone oh god
and i didn't even know true okay i'm
sorry yeah we switched
yeah i didn't even drink this i'm gonna
be as sober as [ __ ]
mickey drank vicky and tiff took no i
didn't
took
well welcome back to big mood we got the
girls here
who's here jessica nikki limo green
oh my god i'm tiffany we're going
government names
yeah she's crazy gina redacted
[Laughter]
what would gina be short for everyone
always asks me if it's short for regina
oh right gina i'm the first one i'm
gonna read anything
it just sounds like regina yeah that's
why i don't like it
the city in canada that's so funny to me
adults
genitals yeah genitalia
do you want to touch my genitalia that's
so
unfortunate yeah all right my whole my
name is just all
genitalia it's very very that well
that's kind of fitting for the episode
today what are we going to talk about
today all right so today i wanted to
talk about
virginity and what it means to us
virginity
virginia great perfect like
girl just quit just quit gina you're
fired how about that
i love cheese i am donald trump you're
fired
it's the last episode of the day
but yeah the reason why i want to talk
about it is because one of you
lovely viewers sent me a message on
a dm and i'm not gonna shout you out
because i don't know if this is personal
to you so i'm not gonna do that
yeah but i will read so she asked two
questions she said number one
is it weird that i keep turning down
every guy that has wanted to take my
virginity
i don't know why i do it um because i do
want to lose it but i just don't know
number two is it weird for me to say
that i am a virgin to some people but at
the same time tell others that i'm not
again
i don't know why so i couldn't i related
to her question because i remember
when i was younger so this girl's
younger than oh yeah by the way she's
16. she does
this she's still a child yes that's not
weird that you're still a virgin
exactly it's not um but i do understand
what
what she's getting at like her question
in terms of like is it weird that this
is the way i'm approaching
my virginity with society because she is
turning down guys that she
would potentially maybe i don't know
want to lose her virginity with but
maybe
she's guarding it for some reason so
that to me was an interesting topic
because for me i was a complete opposite
when i was her age i
felt like virginity was like this thing
i needed to get rid of a loser
because of the people that i was around
too because i mean
you know in the neighborhood i was
living in being 16 and still a virgin
because
that's when i lost my virginity i was
16. it was weird like usually people
lost it way younger
and so for me personally i really wanted
to just be like listen i want to get rid
of this thing so i can already join the
conversations about sex and
understand what everyone's talking about
but afterwards and then now looking
back and now me being an adult and
and realizing um the decisions i made
just really
made me rush into something i don't
think i was ready for
so i feel like if for me personally if i
could give my younger self advice is
just be like hey just
take it slow there's no need to need
there's no need to
to rush into what society is already
doing
and you don't need to feel like you're
being left out because that's something
just really important to you as a person
or whatever like whoever values their
virginity
you know yeah i think that um like it's
it's almost unfortunate now speaking as
someone who's 33 years old
to look at a 16 year old and and like
listen to her
talk about like oh i kind of want to get
rid of it but i kind of don't like i
feel like i should and then i kind of
lie to people about it and it's like
this girl's 16 and like it's like
it's weird that at that age she has to
feel
like either one she's not fitting in
because of that
or like she's missing out on something
and i'm like girl sex with guys half the
time
sucks you're not missing out the first
few times it's gonna suck
really bad um and then also it's like
it's a huge thing because your life kind
of
is is split like pre-sex life
and then post-sex life you're never
going to be the same again so it is a
big
difference um and i'm glad that she's
not like taking that decision lightly
because she will know
she will basically you do kind of lose
your innocence at that point like you're
not the same
um and your mind gets thrown off track
into the dick sand
after after having your time today i'm
[Laughter]
but um yeah i mean i don't think um it's
bad at all that
that you i feel like honestly if you can
hold out
even longer that's probably going to be
healthy for you but also if you
don't want to hold out that's okay too i
lost mine
at 14 i was almost 15. it was a few
weeks before my 15th birthday
i don't necessarily regret that but if i
would have waited longer to like 18 or
something i think maybe that could have
taken my life in a different direction
because i was already like
getting becoming obsessed with boys too
young whereas like i should have been
more focused on myself
my school like you know everything that
that would get me ahead
i was already kind of like lost in boy
land and where my life could have maybe
uh jump started towards making myself
a better person not being that's exactly
what it is
yeah and that's not necessarily just
because you lost your virginity right
it's more like um
your hormones are going crazy and during
that time you're like
you know you're surrounded by boys in
high school now and all of a sudden you
find them yeah but then i think once i
once i did start having sex it's like
that became then like a game to play
or like you know like it definitely
changed the course of who i was like
oh now i'm gonna go to this party and
i'm actually gonna try to get that guy
to like have sex with me so instead of
just like
you know like oh i go out and like oh
but i'm just going to go back home later
and still do my homework you know it's
there you there is a big difference from
like pre-sex me to post-sex me i turn
into a huge [ __ ] [ __ ] afterwards
it's so interesting though um because i
was different than that um i
i guess not i don't say opposite i
wasn't opposite but i guess
i i was always more socially behind
and so most of my school i was very
good grades girl like got like studied
got good grades all that [ __ ] um
i always like wanted to be like a
girlfriend or whatever i was super shy
around guys until i got my first
boyfriend
and even then we were dating for over a
year
um and i thought like i was gonna wait
till marriage to have sex like it was
very
like people don't have sex before
they're married or if you did like
that's
like really taboo like and i only knew a
few people that had had sex
in my friend group that i was like oh my
gosh i can't believe they did it
so young and i don't know if i just was
in a bubble
because i'm sure like tons of other
people at my school were doing it i just
was so
nerdy that i was like oh my gosh
it's not even like a thing oh my god
um and so yeah then when i decided like
well i'm probably going to marry
my boyfriend like i'm probably going to
marry him
how cute we're so dumb
so we decided to i was going to lose my
virginity and it took three times
because it hurts so
bad and i even thought that was a sign
that maybe i shouldn't
do it maybe i should have been waiting
till marriage god is like smiting your
vagina and he's like
no but even after that because like
sex to me was more about the connection
with him than about the sex
because we we were in love and like i
felt
very connected i i didn't just want to
have sex
with guys like i really felt like you
had to feel like you were going to marry
them because even after we broke up i
was like okay well
i [ __ ] up but the next guy i'm gonna
marry him
beforehand that's so weird because it
just turned into a conquest for me well
see that happened
after like 25. i maybe just
yeah i was i was early on that one i i
really didn't open up sexually
until i took that pole dancing class
that i told you guys about like when i
was 21 i was very goofy about sex i was
very like
i don't know you know and um i was it
was really
hard because as an actress they kept
sending me out
on these like sexy roles like sexual
roles because
that's just what my look was you're hot
i like an exotic looking
you know i was like ethnically ambiguous
[Music]
no but i'm like really smart like so
like i can't be hot outside
with the glasses and her hair in a
ponytail yeah except they didn't have
glasses because i had 20 20 visions so
it was like
really difficult to like understand
at least she had braces guys well this
was like after i got him off so
yeah she was hot but i still felt like i
had crooked teeth in the inside
you know it's in there still yeah i get
it but after
getting sexually liberated by that pole
dancing class and then
uh finding good sex slipping into that
dick sand
well you gotta have a lot of sex in
order for it to feel good
so that's the catch 22. and there's just
different partners that i feel like
yeah they're like i didn't know what was
what it was missing
in sex i thought people were over hyping
sex too much
and then i actually had good sex and i
was like
holy 25 i was like 23 or 4 at that point
so it ain't gonna happen in your teens
probably no yeah but it could i think
it's good but then you don't know yeah
they're older
so it wasn't until after that that i was
like not only have i had good sex
but i'm also sexually liberated and i'm
happy
and i know i'm hot right and i have 20
20 vision and i have really
low self-esteem so please fill this void
oh yeah
this huge hole yeah it's very huge
but it's still great it's still great
yeah and tight somehow yeah yeah
yeah got it it's a tight huge hole huge
and it's got length you know
i'm doing my kegels right now leave me
alone oh i just did one as soon as you
said that
yeah now i did two there you go now
we're let's do it at the same time it's
kegel reminder ready
three two one and
where we go whatever we want and wrap
it strengthens your butthole too anyways
does it strengthen your pelvic floor
yeah it is your your your that's what's
moving i think
you're contracting your pelvic floor you
happen to feel it more because i have a
really
bad pelvic floor obviously how did that
happen
like i laugh and pee like i i don't know
oh i sneezed during here yesterday
the other day i am done dude when i had
bronchitis it was just like
coughing and peeing it was a mess
splatter of a 57 year old yes
that's why i'm frightened of having
children oh yeah you're going to be
blown out
diapers for a while it's very hot i'm
very hot guys
conversation i'm just [ __ ] just
ripping my kegels right now
i gave everyone boners and took them all
away i want i want to be able to crush a
wiener
with how strong oh my goodness damn
sometimes when i do it i get chills
do you ever do a kegel and you get
killed yeah
what is that like after you come oh no
no like right now i just like if i do
like one or two then i go
oh yeah true true it's not like an
orgasm it's just a chill yeah like i
feel it in my life
anyway back to virginity yeah no so when
you were what you were saying
jess it really resonated with me because
of the fact that i got pregnant so young
so i felt um there was actually a good
chunk of my 20s where i felt
really guilty about feeling this way but
i did feel very
resentful or not resentful what's the
word regretful regretful that i lost my
virginity so young and i became a mother
so young
but obviously there's a beautiful side
in it which i you can feel two things at
once
which is the fact that i do love my son
i'm sorry he's cool
yeah we need to normalize like feeling
two things that yeah
like yeah yeah yeah and have your son
but also wish that you hadn't
you know yeah yeah he asked me to he's
like
do you regret having me so young and i
was of course not going to say a child
yes because that is i mean that honestly
is the truth it's a complicated question
exactly i couldn't answer that
especially for a 12 year old you have to
say i don't regret you
that's what it is so that's what i ended
up saying i was like no i don't regret
it
it shaped me into who i am today and i
love who i am today
and you know obviously i love you you
you're all these things right
i did mention however i was like the one
thing i do
wish i would have done differently is
wait longer and wait until i was ready
more mature you would have had a way
better mother
than what you ended up having you had a
teenager for a mother and a lot of
bad came out of that really honestly
because i was so immature and impatient
i didn't know what i was doing
but for those reasons that's the main
like the the reason
why i do say that if i could go back in
time and just you know not
lose my virginity so yeah or like view
virginity from a different lens
i would i would have waited as long as i
could because
it's true you really do at least for me
you really
do lose your innocence you're not the
same person anymore
it does change change and shape your
life in a different way
and a lot of people especially at that
age like being so young because i
remember
being 15 and thinking i don't give a
[ __ ] about be different i want to be
different i'm tired of being this like i
don't want to i don't want to be this
child like i want to grow up
i'm ready to grow up and kids want to
grow up so fast yeah
growing up is a scam guys seriously
i don't know i kind of like it just play
with kittens all day
bro i sneezed the other day and i pulled
a muscle you kidding me
you're back you do have to ask yourself
oh yeah
no but i mean yeah so that's the thing
too because and this is something that i
tell isaac all the time because he's 12
and i'm like dude
you have no idea but right now and i
know it feels like an eternity because
it's been your whole life
but you being a child is gonna
go so fast next thing you know you're
gonna be an adult and you're stuck
being an adult for the rest of your life
and you'll never again
understand or feel that that innocence
and like that joy of being a child
and i try to tell him as much as like
obviously i'm his parents so he's in one
year not the other but i'm like
you have no idea like you really don't
know like just stay a kid and enjoy it
because it's it changes forever and you
can't go back
yeah i feel like i'm a super sex
positive person i have a very high body
count
over 20 under 50. good job i honestly
don't know where it's at at this point
i'm probably under 42 but um but yeah i
feel like though the older i get the
more i do kind of feel like yeah holding
on to that and like focusing as a woman
focusing more just on your own personal
growth and things like that and not
because i do think you do you get caught
up in relationships you get caught up in
sex you get caught up
in when you have sex with the man it
releases or i guess even
any kind of sex with any gender it
releases a lot of chemicals so you
you you stop really focusing on yourself
and your own life and you start focusing
on relationships and everything like
but when you're young it's really not
the time for that like you're not mature
enough to be in a relationship you're
really just
sidetracking your life so the more sex
you're having the more you're gonna get
unl until you're married and you know
this is your life and it's set up but
before that if you're having a ton of
sex with a ton of different people
um just so focused on that kind of stuff
you're you're really not focusing on
on your life and making it better um
bettering yourself before that partner
comes so i feel like i've kind of
like changed my thoughts a little bit on
like having sex so young or having so
much sex so young it's like
there's better things you could be doing
with your time true you know
for sure because i i think about this
topic a lot
too because of the fact that i have a
kid and he's getting closer to that age
where he's gonna be going
and it's hard it's hard to tell like a
six to you know sixteen-year-old boy
with a boner
no god weird no i think about that i
don't think about that
but the thing is too like i i've i've
already like made my own internal
decision like i'm not gonna
tell him not to have sex because
obviously he's not gonna [ __ ]
whatever his mom says isn't gonna matter
exactly it's not gonna matter so i i i
wanna opposite just
loves telling that you love sex so much
and gross them out
yeah usually the opposite happens first
[ __ ] just really first psychology
just be like a mom loves dick she's
taking trains
to scare the [ __ ] out of him no because
you know what happened
that that just sparked a memory so when
i was 13
or 12 or 13 i remember being in mexico
and i was with my stepmom
and she asked me randomly and we didn't
have like a
tight connection she was significantly
younger than my dad like 20 years
younger so she was closer to my age
and so um she had this weird thing with
me so we weren't that tight
but the point is this one day she was in
a good mood she was talking to me
and she was asking me like hey are you
still a virgin and i was like yes
like i'm like 13 dude yes of course i'm
a virgin and she goes
weird yeah and then she goes oh you're a
virgin oh my gosh
oh you don't even know how amazing sex
oh
yeah they're so good your dad is just so
amazing
it's so toxic it's so gross but i'm
saying
like that i didn't think about that
again yeah so it didn't work i still
wanted to
lose my virginity at 16 or maybe she
like incepted me subconsciously where i
wanted to experience but also you were
still so young that i don't think it was
nothing was really going to happen at 13
for you because you just weren't really
there so it did take several more years
for you to actually get there hormonally
anyways thankfully
yeah you weren't around any weirdos i
think it's gross how like
virginity is so different for male and
female it's
like if you're yeah if you're a woman oh
you lost your virginity your used goods
but if you're a man like oh you lost
your virginity you're a real man now
you know do you guys think that there's
an endless like stream of virgins
like there's half women and half men in
the world and if they want to have as
much sex as they want to have with all
these different women y'all are going to
run out of [ __ ] virgins
it's math okay what do you think like
math
what do you think is going to happen
girls are kids they're getting more than
one guy
and then they become virgins when
they're well i think it's just the idea
because biologically
men are trying to spread their seed you
know they try to
you know spread their bloodline but also
not take care of another person's seed
yeah you have to be a virgin exactly
yeah and then women
like you got to be home taking care of
the kids you can't be out [ __ ] a
bunch of dudes you gotta be like
just one one man very outdated take care
of that
you know what's interesting too is like
the whole misconceptions are around the
hymen
so for those of you that don't know the
hymen is like this little very thin
tissue and it's different for for all
women too
because there's some hymen that's like
completely sealed
there's some hymen that just has like a
little hole in the middle there's some
that have like
multiple holes and there's some that
women don't even have a hymen
and so the thing around the whole hymen
thing is that back in the day
yeah like popping your cherries so back
in the day they used to
examine girls to make sure that they
were virgins because they needed to have
that
hymen intact and women would actually
get killed if they didn't have
hymens back then you know what that
reminded me of t.i
would get his daughter's highness how
[ __ ]
gross [ __ ] gross first of all who the
like that's your daughter
second of all like your own body dude
leave her alone there's no scientific
proof behind that like you're literally
working on an antiquated like idea like
hyman's do not tell you whether or not a
girl is a virgin first of all second of
all hymns can repair themselves
because it is human tissue just like if
you get a cut you're gonna it's gonna
heal up so if
a hymen is like open or whatever it
could close back up or whatever it is
like
that's just some [ __ ] medieval [ __ ]
dude like grow up that's what happens to
me it keeps closing back up because
every time it feels like i'm losing my
virginity no your husband just has a
massive cockroach yeah
yeah you're tight jesus
jess look at my hair gina you have the
the cutest [ __ ] colored hair right
now
it's purple it's like it's got all these
different shades of what is in there
i have purple blue peel purple blue pink
but then the majority on the top is
this like silver purple you know what i
use to take care of it just what do you
use
functional beauty i love i love function
of beauty
i've been using function of beauty for
like a year and a half now um and i've
only repurchased once that's how long
those bottles last they're pretty big
solid bottles with a lot of product the
16 ounce ones they
and what i like about them is it's not
super watered down like it's it's like
not like the grocery store shitty
two-in-one shampoos that are
you know 56 percent water i don't trust
a person that uses a two in one
yeah well i mean let me try to get a lot
of menus two and one so are you saying
you don't trust men
when i go up with a man and i see like a
three in one i i block him on social
media before oh no no no no
that i i forgive the men i forgive the
men for for using that but you guys
have a pass you girls we all have very
different hair
we have a lot of hair to deal with well
most of us do
unique issues function of beauty makes
it easy to take care of your
personalized issues
they have um a ton of formulations i
think what do we say like a trillion
formulations or something like that
way too many formulations along with
hair care they now offer customizable
body wash and body
lotion i can't wait till they build up
their whole brand i'm just going to buy
all of this stuff
the new body wash and lotion are
tailored to your skin moisture level and
other preferences
and you can pick your favorite color and
fragrance just like with the hair care
function of beauty's formulas always use
clean ingredients are cruelty free and
every bottle is individually formulated
to give you
what you need to look and feel your best
so what are you waiting for go to
functionalbeauty.com
big mood to take your four-part hair
profile quiz and save 20
on your first order that's
functionalbeauty.com
big mood for 20 off and let them know
you heard about it from our show
functionalbeauty.com big mood
so going back to this question uh from
the viewer
so her second question was is it weird
that i
lie to people about my virginity and
that really brought me back to when i
was
a virgin i remember feeling the societal
pressures of needing to know
what inside joke like inside sex jokes
that people were saying especially
because of the media and like you know
movies and music right now we have
[ __ ] as like yeah so a lot of people
anthem
so a lot of people virgins are probably
feeling like oh man like maybe i should
hide this like maybe it's like yeah you
shouldn't even be
talking about so i don't know do you
guys remember that movie kids
from the night watch it well i remember
watching it so it's this like pretty
crazy graphic movie um about kids and
like drugs and sex and all this is it 13
huh 13 or it's another one it's called
kids
i think but yeah you can look it up
anyways but i just remember i think
during that movie there was a point
where the with this one girl she went
and like
gave a blow job for the first time or
something and then all the girls
gathered around her and they're like
what does it taste like what is it like
blah blah so i i'm putting myself
in in the mind of that and she would
just i think she said something like oh
it kind of tastes like butter or
something like that
and i remember thinking like ew i have
never been so disgusted
from a sentence in my life i know i know
but then
so it's just like um like feeling kind
of
like oh there's this like new exciting
thing like she has the secret she knows
what's you know what what a penis tastes
like
you know so it's like i get that in high
school like there is that pressure so
if you're with a crowd of girls that
have like all given head and had sex and
stuff of course you're going to want to
be like
oh yeah yeah i'm cool i know what's up
you know and then if you're around the
nerds like nikki limo you're going to be
like
yeah dude i don't know i have no idea
i'll tell you how nerdy i am i looked up
how to give a [ __ ]
on google um wait like you have yours
jeeves
yeah it was when google was new it
wasn't very good because they also
looked up had mastered we had to put
like the pluses
you had to put yeah keywords only you
couldn't put like a sentence
yeah yeah you couldn't be like how do
this like yeah you had to be like
blow job best moves
[Laughter]
yeah exactly
but um i went i there was only a few
posts up because google was like no no
yeah
it was crap it was not good um but i
studied the [ __ ] out of it because i
wanted to be prepared so that if i ever
did
get presented you did homework for blowj
they said it was the best one they've
ever gotten really so
and what'd you do girl give me you know
you give me supporters
i sucked a lot of dicks but i'm not sure
if i feel as good as you control your
tongue
around it while it's in your mouth yeah
all right first of all i gotta cover
your teeth though oh yeah
that's a very nice tongue you're not
very inclusive for a short time people
um
maybe you can get a tongue extension
yeah get a tongue extension
get a tongue piercing oh no that's too
old for something sorry
yeah no well you do that cover your
teeth for sure for sure
also they said like to get it really
really wet first like
yeah like lick the entire thing lots of
saliva from the base to the tip
yeah like to get it just completely
soaking wet
and then like you kind of tease like
slow your way into it too
you know just like a girl get giving
yeah getting
oral you don't just [ __ ] go right at
it yeah you gotta kind of work your way
you keep them on the edge of their seat
like what's coming next what's
going to happen oh my god she's just
she's even scraping that's what not to
do that's a really flat dick dude
her two fingers are not a dick shape
yeah
um yeah so i like was like taking notes
like making sure
i was i was studying that i imagine your
parents came across these notes
i used to print out erotica stories
and then i would shred them the pieces
so my parents could never find it
honestly i feel like you did way too
much work because the guys aren't
[ __ ]
doing this [ __ ] like that for us when
we're young there's no
guy that's like how do i eat a
fictionalist though i was like i need to
know like
because i didn't want to be laughed at
like for not like that's how you do it
i don't even know how it's supposed to
be done i know
i didn't know that though i was like i
don't wanna look like a noob
i'm gonna say girls that are young don't
[ __ ] do homework to give a [ __ ]
figure it out over time they don't
deserve a good [ __ ] at 16. that's
true
also figure out what you like too
because that was
the hardest part was guiding them when
they're giving you oral
like to what you like to make you orgasm
don't be too shy to tell them what you
want because this is a whole this is a
two-person job man
yeah everybody's gotta [ __ ] work
together yeah but like if you're 16 year
old and if you're not
you're not gonna yeah i mean you have to
get older and more comfortable with
yourself
plus everyone's vagina's different so a
guy that's like
dude i'm so good at giving oral or
whatever like
he does he's good for that one girl yeah
maybe she really likes it but then he
tries the same move on the next girl
maybe she lied that's probably the truth
yeah she lied so remember guys and girls
all everyone we all have the same
parts just arranged in different ways
because like mexican food
yeah exactly pretty much the exact thing
it's just a different shape but
it is the soulmate this is exactly like
the taco but it's flat i don't
understand
but it still tastes good yeah so the
reason why i say that is because
it's also kind of [ __ ] up how our
society is so fixated on
on misinformation with like cultural
cultural misinformation like what i said
earlier about the hymen and also
like about how tight or how loose or
like lips inside
lips outside your nipples like inverted
or whatever it is like
yeah people at all the biggest one is
guys thinking like if you've had sex
multiple times that your vagina's gonna
be way looser yeah
every time i see that comment and i'm
just like dude you're definitely i'm
like
yeah yeah you just called yourself out
so hard one gauge looser that's not a
virgin anymore
and had sex that's the one gauge that it
gets looser i mean your virgin vagina is
obviously different from not a virgin
one but that it doesn't [ __ ]
continuously get
wider and wider and it's not consistent
too because they're like well she had
sex with a lot of dudes so she's loose
but what about one woman who had sex
with one guy who exactly
a thousand times so yeah
in that logic if if i [ __ ] five guys
once i'm looser than nicki who's [ __ ]
her one dude six thousand times like
that doesn't
make sense at all and that's six
thousand and one six thousand times
that's actually the problem too around
sex and in in
cultural opinions because then they
become like quote unquote facts when
they're actually
not facts and not even based on science
because if you just take one second
to think about it like what you had
literally just said you can see how
that's just
it makes no sense google's free [ __ ]
look at that a girl that was
much better now a girl that was married
for 10 years to one guy her vagina's
supposedly tighter than mine
right sure not just that but then i
guess like like uh
again like with the cultural fixation
and also with porn they're always
showing you like the cleanest like
[ __ ] all the way in like lips in kind
of thing very clean very like no hair no
nothing no
blemishes at all but people forget that
they actually
have post editing like they edit the
videos or whatever and also they've had
a lot of cosmetic surgery whatever it is
everyone is different literally every
single person is different
and everything is normal and that's the
thing that i'm i'm currently learning
through this book that i've been reading
called come as you are by um
emily nagowski and it's such a good book
like it's
really opening my mind and making me
feel like oh my gosh what's the spark
notes on that book
what is it about what she's talking
about is a lot of like how
women's brains like the way we are when
it comes to arousal and just
desire oh i learned this really so guys
should read this [ __ ] yeah no
guys definitely a hundred percent
it called men and women come as you are
but it's not yes
come as you are it's so good so uh what
i've learned recently is this thing
called
uh arousal non-concordance and that's
the [ __ ] is that
my [ __ ] mind so what it means is when
um
so you know how commonly we we think
that if a man has a boner he is horny
he's ready for sex
that's not true there's a lot of
instances where your gender
or women if we are turned on and horny
and we're not wet that means we're lying
like a lot of people think
oh you're lying you're a [ __ ] liar
but that's not true there's this thing
that happens so for
i think it i forgot the stats already
but for men i think it's like
50 or 60 where it overlaps which is
when they are like their brain is turned
on and their genitals are turned on it's
a 50 or 60
overlap like yes this is correct wait so
half the time you have boners they don't
want them
yes yeah that makes sense get them in
class or the other way
as a young kid but like as a grown man
yeah with half of their boners
half of their boners are unnecessary and
not just their boners it's when they're
aroused and they can't get a boner
like the same thing
it's freaking crazy so then it's also oh
but for women
i think it's like 40 like it's lower
so for us like that happens often too
where it's like our brain wants sex
but our vaginas are not responding in
terms of getting wet or the other way
around where it's like
like there was this one example that she
used in the book where a friend of hers
said that
her partner they were trying something
kinky where uh she got
like she was completely nude he tied her
hands up
like up on something and then he put a
broomstick
in between her legs and then he left and
she was just there and she was like
i'm [ __ ] bored like i'm not into this
like this is not my thing
and then inside of her no like just laid
it on like just make sure you hold it
like
like a witch like writing a broomstick
kind of thing so just holding it there
and then when he came back she was like
yeah i'm not into this like let's try
something else and he's like oh really
you're not into it then why are you so
wet
and so that's that's a rousing
non-concordance her body reacted to
something that's
sexually relevant to the body rape cases
too
yeah right yeah yeah that's why they say
that men can't
get raped that's a like but a lot of men
are like i didn't agree my body betrayed
me
yeah exactly yeah that's arousal
non-concordance the same thing with
women because they would get raped and
they would still climax and have an
orgasm they feel terrible for it
yeah and then also i learned through
this book that back in the day
if a woman oh so like um
so the way society views men and women
sex sexual experiences is that women are
like
men light meaning we have the same
desires the same arousal the same kind
of like or
we we get horny but not the same as men
because it's like the light version
discount men yeah yeah like the app or
the app that we didn't pay the full
thing
so they think they think that when the
free room on turns us on
exactly just less often yes so that's
how that's like
way wrong so that's how the culture
really is about it such a man way of
thinking
for sure it's not just men it's it's as
a society like as a culture this is how
we've all viewed
sex between men and women and through
this book i'm learning like
what the [ __ ] like no like women are a
completely
different being like we have completely
different desires and arousals and like
our bodies react differently our bodies
are shaped differently it's
all we all have the same parts arranged
in different ways which she repeats in
this book a thousand times but i
honestly
super super recommend this book it's
really educational i'm gonna go read
that
yeah i used to like get horny in my head
but um
like my birth control wouldn't let me
get wet like
it was a problem you know i had to
switch birth control up but i was on it
for like a year
and i had i had to use lube all the time
and i thought that was totally normal
until like i switched birth control and
i was like oh [ __ ] my my body can make
it
like its own personal control does that
anti-depressant yeah
certain medications can do that so not
just that i'm talking about getting wet
sorry gina it's because i'm so excited
about this topic
it makes me happy i love your passion i
learned so much so i'm just so like
okay so the other thing when i was on
ask the fields
which is another youtube channel from
long island i was on it yeah yeah
so during that show and also just to
point out i was like
super camera shy so yeah that was
that was like early early too early tiff
days in front of the camera and so i
struggled a lot to contribute to that
show but anyway
the only thing that i do remember
contributing quite often is me talking
about how i like to use lube
and people grabbed that information and
said oh tiff can't get wet
like oh she's broken like something's
wrong with her how could she not get wet
like she's definitely not doing
something
all these people had all these opinions
about my body yes so they were like 16
years old
yeah they're all [ __ ] [ __ ] so
then oh but not just that but then it
kind of like turned into this thing
even like outside of the comment section
and
the people were just like oh tiff wants
lube again like tiff with the lube and
it's like what the [ __ ]
it's actually weird you guys can do
anything else i thought like
i don't know that just seemed like a
normal part of sex yeah we learned about
it in sex
ed so that's the thing that is another
like cultural misconception or something
if you need to use lube you're broken
it's very very very incorrect to think
that way because
lube is actually safer to use when
you're having sex because that prevents
um like um harmful friction is what i
was trying to say and tearing
especially if you're doing it in the
butt and
i'm not really a fan of but you need
lube for that
way wouldn't be a booming uh company
yeah
right yeah it's not just like a person
thing you know it's something
crazy that i learned too is that men
need
lube too yeah especially like if you're
not circumcised or something you have
the foreskin that some men like they
actually
it hurts if you just pull it back
without any lube and
if they haven't created their own juices
because of arousal non-concordance
then they need to grab the lube and so a
lot of people
feel shame in that and you don't need to
because it's the most natural normal
thing it's actually good
to use lube yeah a lot of the uh because
i've i've had several uncircumcised
penises and several of them like they
needed it to be more wet like they're
more sensitive yeah
mine's the opposite like he made his own
like it's almost like he made his own
fluid well yeah yeah that can happen too
but
some sometimes they're i mean if they're
dry too but their dicks are definitely
more exciting again everyone's different
yeah
i'm going to say a thousand times same
non-concordant it's the same thing with
me like i remember the same parts
different ways
there was a birth control the nuva ring
made me dry and it killed my lip i
couldn't even make a dirty joke
like yeah just dead right and then at
other times i'm not even turned on but
sometimes it's like the [ __ ] nile
river it's like bro chill
there's nothing going on right now dude
the patch played the meanest prank on me
my boobs got huge like they grew like
two cup sizes
they were so big but it hurt to even
touch them like
brush against them so my boyfriend just
wanted to grab them all day long i was
like i can't even
yeah that's so cool yeah it was so
mean yeah i was like all my life i
wanted big boobs yeah
and then i got them and you can't you
can't touch them life is cruel for women
like this
like i want you to come inside me but
then now i'm stuck with a baby i don't
want that [ __ ] you know like i can never
get anything
so honey is a free browser extension
that finds promo codes for you and
automatically applies them to your cart
there have been so many times especially
right now with our new home we've been
i've been purchasing a lot of things
especially for the new backyard that we
just finished and honey has saved me so
much money
it's been amazing so all you have to do
is when you're shopping you add things
to your cart
you wait a few are and then that's when
honey gives you like a little
notification
lets you know like hey there's some
promo codes that i can use to see if
i'll save you some money
and then so you just click on it you
wait a few seconds as it's cycling
through a whole bunch of codes
and you just watch those savings
go up because you're saving money and
um and the price has dropped so savings
go up prices drop down
we use it almost every day it's
fantastic yeah right it's amazing
so honey has found it's over 17 million
members over
two billion dollars in savings if you
don't already have honey
it's a lot right it's a lot of dollars
so it's simple if you have a computer
honey should be on it it's free and it
works with whatever browser you use
you can get honey for free today at
joinhoney.com
mood that's joinhoney.com
mood it's literally like having a little
old chinese lady haggle everything for
you every time you shop
do you know how great that is i found a
better deal over here
right exactly she's like no no we walk
away and they'll come after us
like it's it's amazing oh and also i
have to i have to mention they give you
a little like
uh chart thingy like for example uh i
was looking
at this this uh surround sound system
and they were like
wait wait wait wait wait if you wait a
little longer the prices are gonna drop
so they even give you like suggestions
and this is a free app so there's no
reason for you guys not to download it
never
browser extension but also if you're
shopping and you're hungry
uh hello fresh is the thing and it's
awesome hello hello i've been cooking so
much at home lately but then sometimes
like i could cook a little bit more but
the thing is i don't really want to go
grocery shopping because then that means
i have to be in public which kind of
sucks
so hellofresh uh cuts out the stressful
meal planning grocery store chips
so you can enjoy cooking and getting
dinner on the table in about 30 minutes
or even less they deliver a box full of
everything that you need for meals and
gives you instructions on how to cook it
even a picture so you can see how to
plate it there's uh over 90
of the ingredients are sourced directly
from growers to ensure the freshest
recipes are delivered to your door
it's uh you can easily change your
delivery days or food preferences and
skip a week whenever you need
uh i personally like and it's always
been my favorite the
the cherry balsamic pork chops that
sounds amazing
cherry balsamic yeah and then if i want
to lie to the world
i cook it if i want to lie to the world
i cook it and i post it on my instagram
store and people are like oh my god
jimmy you're so good at
cooking here's some wifey material and
that's how i trap them
that's how you trap them so if you guys
want out there you guys want to do some
dropping here you go
um so for now uh you can try out
america's number one meal kit
go to hellofresh.com 80 big mood and use
code
80 big mood to get a total of 80 off
across five boxes including free
shipping on your first
box again that's hellofresh.com
slash 80 big mood and use code 80 big
mood
to get a total of eighty dollars off
across five boxes
including free shipping on your first
box make yourself some food
i want a t-shirt with uh
like a someone walking away with a bunch
of hair and then a doll that's bald
that's a lot of doll hairs
that sounds really creepy that's what i
want
i don't imagine i'm getting ready for
our new merch coming out of december
i'm picturing like the toy story doll
that is right
yeah yeah yeah and then spider
[Applause]
[Music]
anything that looks like a spider
deserves to die oh my god
he's so sweet though she helped
she it's ugly don't like it it's ugly
she's a survivor
i love it i just feel like the whole
virginity thing is
it just seems like such a huge daunting
thing in
high school right like everyone when
you're young but then when you grow
older you realize it wasn't that big of
a [ __ ] deal really no
it's not at all i think like there might
be a moment where you're like oh if i
gave it to the
the total [ __ ] guy that didn't have
any feelings for me at all like even
when you're
you know a little bit older you might be
like yeah i could have done that better
but
at the same time it's like once it's
over it's over and it really doesn't
matter anymore like what matters is the
man standing in front of you
you know as you're as you're married or
whatever like whoever [ __ ] you when
you were 16 or 18 doesn't matter
i would say you know ideally
i i would want if i was to do it all
over again like i liked the way that i
lost my virginity to somebody that
where at the afterwards you didn't feel
like something was taken away from you
yeah yeah i feel like i didn't i never
lose mine
yeah like that cause some people um i've
heard some
virginity horror stories where like not
not rape or anything like that but um
like my
one friend she wanted to lose her
virginity
and she got pressured by a cool guy
in school like a popular guy and um she
just wanted to be cool
and she thought that like letting him
take her virginity would like
buy her into the club basically and then
connect her to him in some way yeah
and then it doesn't work like no and
then afterwards he
like didn't talk to her anymore and she
felt
like she tell you yeah so
whatever it is if it's if it's important
to you which i feel like
your sexuality should be somewhat
important what's your body too yeah it's
your body like if
i i feel like you there's a level of
respect
that you should uh have for yourself and
kind of build with yourself and
uh when you're ready to uh share that
with somebody
then then that's the good time to lose
it like
and with a person that you feel
comfortable with losing it too
but if you're gonna at the end of the
day do it to gain
something or do it for like some
alternative purpose or try to
fill a void within yourself i just don't
think it'll work out for you true
no or it might not yeah she could just
wait because it doesn't seem like she's
fully ready there's a guy that's not
sure yeah like don't worry about it girl
just wait yeah because you can
want to lose your virginity it doesn't
mean that you are actually ready
to use your virginity because that seems
what what's happening it seems to be
what's happening
with her because she's saying that she
really wants to but then she's
she's uh tearing uh what is it turning
everyone down that is approaching her
and that she's well they're probably all
scrubs i mean
16 17 year old guys ain't [ __ ] anyway
like i get it
yeah they don't deserve you honey i
remember at one point where i was like
i'm never
gonna have sex because i was very young
yeah it was when i first learned about
sex yeah because uh it just looked
painful
and then even when i lose yeah and then
even when i like got to
where i was really horny like uh where i
was masturbating you know
i could only watch gay porn because
seeing a dick
go into the vagina like made me just
feel like
that was going to be painful yeah even
tampons kind of hurt
so yeah something you were not wanting
to lose it
that's true no i i remember wanting to
ex like now as an adult i kind of wish i
would have explored more with myself
before i jumped into something else like
with someone else like losing my
virginity or whatever because
i had never really gotten to know
how my body even worked i given myself
the permission
to explore my own body like i kind of
first gave it to someone else really
and that's something i kind of wish i
would have i would have gotten to know
more about myself
but yeah i mean because it's something
very sacred to
to the individual and it might not be to
another individual like it kind of
wasn't for me
really i don't know i'm kind of
conflicted with it i kind of feel that
way i guess about
if on the opposite end of promiscuity
it's like
if you feel like yeah like kind of how
we were saying if you feel like you're
gonna feel like you lost it or you're
just doing it to gain something or
whatever
it's it's like there's some girls and i
feel like i
for me it was like i enjoyed
um i don't know like just the game of
sex like
to me it was a game for a long time and
and then then when i got into a
relationship and i'm like oh well this
is
fun um because i'm connecting with
another person but none of my
relationships were really good or actual
love
so but i still enjoyed the game part of
it and i had fun for the game
of having sex um but at the end of the
day a lot of times the sex was like i
would never come anyway because we're
just having a one-night stand or
something so it's not
super fulfilling um so i go back and
forth i think like you do too or it's
like well you could hold it it's super
special and sacred but also at the end
of the day like do i care
that i had a lot of shitty sex
experiences no not really yeah cause
like for me
i didn't so i was hyper aware of not not
being like what our society views as
women like i
did not want to be a hoe or whatever
like i didn't want to be a [ __ ] i didn't
want to sleep with a whole bunch of
people
but i did like the exploration of it so
that's how i i felt conflicted about it
in terms of promiscuity
i just felt like i wanted to explore i
wanted to find out more and i wanted to
have that gain that experience but i
also was very cautious about
not getting a high body count because i
like i
i felt like i was gonna be dirty or
whatever the societal
pressures of that totally like one-sided
for me
because it doesn't matter how many
they've had because i always do that
whole like well if one key opens up a
bunch of locks and it's a good key but
if a
lock is opened up by a bunch of keys and
it's a bad lock kind of thing
everybody's right there
like every [ __ ] few months the
metaphor they use is
if a key can open many locks the dick
can open then that's a good key but if a
lock is opened by many keys and that's a
[ __ ] up lock
because it's not a lock [ __ ] it's not
like so shitty personally it's like
for me if you want to flip it that's
like saying if a pencil sharpener can
sharpen a [ __ ] ton of pencils that's a
good pencil sharpener
yeah yeah
yeah yeah but if a pencil keeps getting
sharpened by it
you're gonna become just a little tiny
nub yeah
which looks like exactly the same length
as the people who use that stupid
[ __ ] metaphor
exactly yeah i think honestly like if if
you if we erased society and culture
like having sex is there's nothing bad
about it like we all have to
progress our species i don't know who
came in probably
men to control women no it actually was
yeah yeah like you learn about that
i recommend the book the only other
thing the only other reason to be
against promiscuity is just for um like
disease
i guess or unplanned pregnancy but if
you're
taking care of that part of it
um and also you're mentally healthy
you're okay with the sex and like what
the transaction is or the emotional
exchanges
then there really isn't an issue with it
so i don't know
i think being raised catholic uh or any
like a lot of religions like um
drilled into like a marriage first um
but then
when i decided to lose it at 16 not only
did i was i like well i'm probably gonna
marry this guy but i also was thinking
about i started questioning like what
made the like when they made those rules
who was making them and back then people
were getting married at 14 to 17 years
old
when they weren't going to live that
long
you're the most fertile so obviously it
was easy for them to be like
get married first yeah but um yeah cause
you're gonna die at 30 anyway
yeah true it's so unhealthy with the
whole like you know you save yourself a
marriage kind of thing like if you guys
want to do it do it but i've heard so
many stories of people who
are literally getting married just so
they can have sex and then yeah shitty
situation it's not going to guarantee
whatever you think it's going to
guarantee it's not going to guarantee
that uh
that marriage is going to last because
you think a man will only love you if
you're pure
it's not going to guarantee that your
relationship is going to be good because
you haven't slept around
so you're only going to value this man
like it's not going to guarantee
whatever you think it's going to
guarantee
it's not going to guarantee a good sex
life it's not no because you're not
going to get to practice and have fun
and
learn new things and compare and
contrast comparisons
that's why i didn't think that i liked
sex that much until i
had good sex and i was like oh [ __ ] i
didn't realize there's a whole another
level
exactly but men shoot themselves in the
foot because the more sexually active
you are the more engaged you become in
sex the more you like sex the more you
get good at sex and then the man
benefits from that so any man that
sleeps with
me is gonna have a good ass time because
honestly virgins would not be that
yeah they would be boring but if you
have some weird ego thing and you just
want the girl to only sleep with you
then have fun with that because it's
happening with that sack of sand
no they don't dis i'm just kidding i'm
kidding no i mean i definitely respect
women that keep it to themselves that
don't have a lot of sex i'm playing a
joke role with that but
um yeah i i i don't know for this girl
girl just [ __ ] how about we just
revisit at 21. i don't think you're
ready
yeah i was trying to trying to figure
out like what constitutes being ready
and i
so that for me it's like when you're
ready when you
feel like you're making the decision
you're not being pressured into making
it sounds like high school pressure is
is getting to her and that's playing
into
i mean sure she's probably curious to
sit there and and just say like
yeah actually i really do want to lose
my virginity it was good this is what i
want
and that and like 100 feel it then i
think you'll know like when the guy
is there and you want him you'll know
when it's time like it's
super easy like i i imagine right now in
the this
exact time it's extra there's extra
pressure
for for teenagers to lose their
virginity because now
as a society i don't know maybe this is
me sounding old or whatever but i do
feel like it is getting
more sexual because even when we were
high school kids it was [ __ ] sexual
extremely crazy it was like booty booty
buddy everywhere rocking everywhere
grinding was huge so sex is like really
like pushed in front of your face
constantly all the time so i get it
there's
there's those pressures but yeah like
like what these ladies just said like
just look within
yourself see if this partner that you're
about to share this with is someone that
you
want to share it with because yeah you
don't want to end up feeling like
someone just
took something from you yeah exactly
because luckily i didn't feel that when
i lost my virginity it was also kind of
like here take it
like not like you're like i'm ready to
get this over with so yeah
can you please help me yeah and even if
the person that you
give it to and you don't work out it's
at the end of the world like it's not
you're not you should expect that it
won't work out like that yeah
but i think all the human mistakes oh
the same advice applies for even now
as an adult you know our age like uh if
you're single still
it's like don't give it to someone who's
gonna make you feel like you've lost
something or who's not gonna respect you
it's like it doesn't even matter so i
think the virginity part of it
doesn't really matter that's just
something to carry for your entire life
men and women actually if you're gonna
feel like oh this girl used me she's a
party girl she used me
she [ __ ] banged me and then now she's
sleeping with chad and i'm now i'm
pissed it's like
well don't give it to someone that you
think you're going to you know be sad
about after like dude honestly i just
recommend
for all you virgins out there just read
that book i just told you
as you are you'll be so educated and
you'll understand
you approach the the topic of sex and
women's bodies even like you yourself if
you're a girl
your body as a woman in a completely
different light a more educated more
like open and understanding light so
or perspective so i highly recommend
that you shouldn't feel
dirty for not yeah there's no reason for
you feel dirty because one it's a very
natural thing this is what we do humans
we reproduce animals reproduce you know
and you shouldn't feel dirty yeah
there's monkeys out there
[ __ ] yeah
yeah you don't want to like sex people
try to push the whole like purity thing
that's [ __ ] stupid you're not gonna
that's just a construct yeah if you lose
your virginity there's not gonna be a
label on your head
yeah it's not there's no scarlet letters
here we are not living we're not gonna
walk
sometimes i'll walk a little differently
if it's a little slower
tips walking like a [ __ ] today yeah she
literally said i knew you lost your
virginity because you started walking
my lips are swollen you know
like some downstairs when they beat the
[ __ ] up
they should get swollen so you might and
then also if you are losing virginity
because
because another thing too like when i
lost my virginity i got
with the guy that i lost it to he made
me feel
like a liar like a ho like like the
worst thing ever
because i didn't bleed from losing my
virginity
that goes back to behind exactly in like
second grade there was two incidences
that happened like within a week
because i i switch off because i don't
know exactly which one did it
but um one where i fell on the crossbar
of my bike
and i was bleeding so many times did you
bleed
yeah yeah and then you lost your
virginity to your bike to my bike
it was a hot bike though
yeah no training wheels yeah no training
wheels and none of that
padding in between the bar you know how
they have the padding thing oh yeah
yeah babe um what was the other incident
the other incident
was i was climbing this uh on our
playground at school they had this thing
they called it the big toy but there was
a it was
all made of wood and they had like this
one plank of wood that was sloping up
and i tried to climb it
and i fell and i fell like right on it
and i had to go to the nurse's office
because it was bleeding
damn um i think i hit mine in gymnastics
too because i was in gymnastics for a
little bit when i was a little girl yeah
they have you on the bars and it's like
you just slam your [ __ ] couch right
on that [ __ ]
yeah dude my mom had to ask me if people
touched me because they were like huge
bruises from gymnastics
but yeah so you don't have to bleed it's
not a
must it's not a requirement for you to
lose your virginity
also virginity has or losing your
virginity has different meanings or
definitions to every person too like
usually is it just penis and vagina or
is there more yeah like everyone has
their own
version of of what virginity is now if
you have it in the butt
is you don't you're still a virgin some
people consider that
girl duo that made that song do it in
the butt because we love jesus
i don't remember what it was cause they
want to keep their virginity i forgot
that does not mean they can't
see like see like this construct and
then these [ __ ]
loopholes and like [ __ ] that we make
like come on
i wish it wasn't even just called a
virginity anymore can you just ask
people like hey you got
you had sex before yeah you know like
who the [ __ ] cares well then like what's
the
card the pop in the cherry like
everything's just like a trophy too
they were banged yeah all right cool
and on that note thank you guys so much
for watching this episode make sure
to subscribe if you haven't like this
video
and if you're watching this on itunes it
helps us so much
greatest five stars we love you so much
make sure to comment down below what
your thoughts are on this episode and
we'll see you next time